كان آرون جيمس يعمل كعامل
خط جهد عالي في عام 2021 عندما
لمس وجهه بطريق الخطأ سلكًا حيًا، فقد
ذراعه وأجزاء من
وجهه، تركه واقع جيمس الجديد غير
قابل للتعرف عليه تقريبًا ولا يتذكر ما
حدث، وتم إرساله إلى مستشفى في
تكساس.
بعد فترة طويلة من استيقاظي، استيقظت في حالة تأهب
واستيقظت بعد 6 أسابيع في دالاس،
تكساس، سرعان ما علم الأطباء في جامعة نيويورك
بحالته ورأوا
إمكانية ذلك بعد أقل من عامين من
وقوع الحادث، حيث أجروا عملية
زرع جزئية ناجحة للوجه وزرع عين كاملة في المرة
الأولى.  حدث هذا في
التاريخ وهذا ما يبدو عليه جيمس
الآن، العين الجديدة لا تزال غير مفتوحة ولكنها
تتلقى تدفق الدم، يقول أطبائه
عندما تمشي بجوار المرآة، هل
تتوقف عن نفسك وتذهب أوه نعم واو في كل
مرة أرى مرآة  سأتوقف، إنه أمر
لا يصدق في البداية، لقد
كانت نظرة سيئة، لقد كانوا يجهزونني بشكل أساسي
لموته، هل
فقدت الأمل من قبل، لا لماذا هذا لأنه كان
يقاتل ابنتهما ألي لم تكن متأكدة من
شكله ولكن هذا  ليس ما اهتمت به هو أن
معظم مخاوفي كان فقط كيف سيكون
عندما يكون مستيقظًا واعيًا، هل
اعتقدت يومًا أنك ستفقده؟
نعم، أعتقد أنني ما زلت في حالة صدمة قليلاً،
لذلك أنا فقط أحب ذلك.  كيف
تعرف أن الإجراء الذي يستغرق 21 ساعة
كان معقدًا على كل المستويات،
لماذا تعد إضافة حرف i إلى عملية زرع الوجه
أكثر تعقيدًا بكثير من
عملية زرع الوجه المعقدة بالفعل، إنها
منطقة مجهولة تمامًا، ساعد الدكتور إدواردو رودريغيز في
قيادة العملية التاريخية  أجرى عملية جراحية في إحدى
غرفتي العمليات، حيث قام بتشريح الوجه
الذي سيحصل عليه جيمس قريبًا بما في ذلك
العين التي فصلناها عن المتبرع
ويبدأ السباق في هذه المرحلة، حيث
لا يتلقى الوجه والعين
أي إمداد دم خلال مقدار الوقت الذي
لا يستغرقه ذلك.  تلقي الدم أمر بالغ الأهمية
يمكن أن تموت العين لذلك آخذ الوجه من
غرفة المتبرع إلى غرفة هارون وأبدأ
كل تلك
التوصيلات مضطرًا إلى استخدام المجهر
لتوصيل أعصاب لا يزيد
عرضها عن ملليمتر لتوصيل العين هل هناك
احتمال ذلك  سوف يرى في
المستقبل في هذه المرحلة، فهو لا يرى
ولكن حقيقة أن العين موجودة، فقد
خطونا بالفعل خطوة كبيرة
للأمام، لقد
كان جيمس يرى نفسه
لأول مرة بعد
الجراحة، لا تنظر إلى هذا على أنه
خط النهاية، هذا هو أكثر من نقطة بداية على الإطلاق، حيث
يرى جيمس
هدفًا أكبر من
هدفه، وهذا حقًا أكبر أمل لي في
هذه الصفقة، أعني أنه إذا كان بإمكاني رؤية ذلك
فهذا أمر
رائع لكنني سأبدأ في المرحلة التالية
فئة في مجال metd وفي كل
محكمة [الموسيقى].